il m'a fallu très longtemps pour
connaître
de quelle maladie j'étais atteinte
au départ la pose du diagnostic s'est
fait au bout de nombreuses années parce
que justement la recherche n'êtes pas
suffisante
on n'avait pas assez d'avancé pour
connaître quel était le gène touchés
quelle est exactement la maladie dans
j'étais atteinte et tout ça c'est grâce
dons du téléthon qui ont permis ces
recherches et qui permettent aujourd'hui
que mes enfants soient dépistés que mes
petits enfants le seront et donc ça à
pantin bien-être un confort de vie
parce qu'on est suivi tous les jours un
personnel
et des bénévoles qui nous aident au jour
le jour dans notre quotidien
donc tout ça c'est quand
pour aider les malades et leurs familles
alors vous aussi faites un don le 2 et
le 3 décembre la réunion tel est ton
pays nous défient contre la maladie